earlier in the week we reported during
the show that dak Prescott won't
participate in the Cowboys virtual
offseason training program without his
long-term deal the plan was for Prescott
not to be there for the normal offseason
program but obviously there isn't gonna
be a normal offseason program at least
not for now and Stephen Jones the
Cowboys CEO Oh kind of shrugged at the
news saying well it's all voluntary and
he's gonna have his iPad and yada yada
look the bottom line is you're trying to
get your team ready for its first season
with Mike McCarthy and you're simulating
what it would be like to have meetings
and sessions at your facility and the
most glaring absence is going to be your
starting quarterback I think it is
significant I think it is something you
don't shrug at and this is Prescott's
effort short of the July 15 drop-dead
date for doing a long-term deal this is
his effort to squeeze the Cowboys to
finally get him taken care of and I
understand why he's doing it you got to
use what you can to try to leverage the
team to finally do the right thing and
give you the contract you've been trying
to get doesn't at some point the Jones
family have to put up the white flag
I mean I I just I'm so curious about it
not that I really don't care whether dak
Prescott makes 36 million over five or
thirty four I I don't I don't really
care and I don't think fans really care
but with a new head coach if the
quarterback is not involved in the
installations and he's not making every
effort in July when you can carefully in
doing it the right way be throwing to
your receivers with new offensive stuff
it I mean I just think at some point the
Cowboys have to basically say okay let's
let's draw a line in the middle and
compromise and let's each meet in the
middle because this is this has just
gone on too long the Cowboys blew it at
the beginning by Mike we've talked about
this before have you ever in your life
one time ever ever seen a quarterback
negotiate
we're on you know July 9th you paid less
than what you offered on January 1st
I mean prices don't go backwards they
don't do that prices go up I don't know
which way I'm going but you know you
know what I'm saying do the right thing
get this done stop the madness right now
and look I think one of the concerns is
the true deadline is July 15 you don't
want to move to your bottom line
prematurely because you will be squeezed
off that when the real deadline arrives
in the middle of July but wherever the
Cowboys currently are dak Prescott
clearly doesn't like it and people will
say to me why are you always supporting
the player in these in these situations
well I would assume that over the past
decade as we've become more sensitive to
the physical demands and the real risk
that the players take we would be more
sensitive to the notion that they should
get every dollar they can while they can
get it but beyond that the Cowboys at
every turn have taken advantage of the
devices in place to keep that Prescott
around for the lowest possible cost they
squatted on him for his entire rookie
contract he made two million in salary
last year they didn't renegotiate the
deal they didn't take away the injury
risk from him last year and then they
used the franchise tag to keep him off
the market I keep coming back to that
Peter once you activate the process that
is the franchise tag you have to accept
the fact that the player has rights
under that process as well whether it's
staying away from the off season program
whether it's skipping training camp and
all of the preseason and showing up just
before the start of the season and
making the full amount of the franchise
tender like Le'Veon Bell did back in
2017 or whether it's skipping the whole
year and forcing your way to the market
like Bell did in 2018 the player has
rights
the team has rights and if the team
wants to avoid the player having the
ability to do those things just don't
use the franchise tag and go out and
sign them in competition with the open
market Peter I have no idea what that
Prescott would get on the open market
but I have a feeling that the Cowboys
probably would have gotten a better deal
if they
just let dak see what else is out there
cuz I don't think anyone else is gonna
offer him what he's able to leverage
under the franchise tag by squeezing the
Cowboys the way that he is maybe Mike
but it only takes one and if you're not
willing to live with the bluff calling
with either result of the bluff calling
I wouldn't do it that way I would not
have done that i Mike what what is
important in this case you know I wrote
a couple of weeks ago a few weeks ago
that Mike McCartney the agent for Kirk
Cousins who's done all these great deals
for cousins basically because he and
cousins have never been afraid of
playing at the franchise number most
quarterbacks want to get the guaranteed
number as absolutely as high as you can
alright so now you look and see okay
Kirk Cousins 33 point Oh you know in
golf 33 five okay those decisions and
those numbers are result to me of smart
business operations and the fact is that
Kirk Cousins even though he isn't a top
five quarterback in football he's paid
like one because he and his agents have
been willing to stare into the abyss and
say I'm fine with a one-year deal I'll
just play on this I have confidence in
myself and at the end of this year I'm
gonna get paid again and every single
decision he's made financially along
with Mike McCartney his agent had been
absolutely correct and I think Jack
Prescott is gonna move in that same
direction unless he gets what he wants
on a long-term deal play this year under
the franchise tag 20% raise next year
and then the Cowboys to get him for that
third year would have to give him a 44
percent raise over what he makes next
year with the 20% raise over the
franchise number this year it gets to
the point where you just can't do it and
you have to let him get to the open
market and Peter here's why I think that
the Cowboys should have considered
calling Dax Bluff because I don't know
who would have been out there to say
we're gonna give him 35 million a year
and even
if you're giving him 35 million a year
which is what he apparently wants from
the Cowboys you're not giving him the
spot as the starting quarterback of the
Dallas Cowboys you're the starting
quarterback of some other team that is
not the Dallas Cowboys and the earning
potential that goes along with that goes
away so you almost have to offer what
how much more - three four million more
per year - to get him to not be the
Cowboys quarterback I think I think the
Cowboys really could have made a power
play here if they wanted to and they
could have said we're not gonna tag you
we're gonna we're gonna offer you
something or just do transition tag have
the right of first refusal but whatever
it is say hey you want to leave fine
we'll go get Cam Newton we'll go after
Tom Brady we'll find somebody else and
we're not gonna let you hold us hostage
I'm just I wonder if they thought about
it and I'm a little bit surprised they
didn't do it
because I think at the end of the day
Dax gonna realize his best places with
the Cowboys I guarantee you they thought
of it because Jerry Jones thinks of
things like that and I absolutely
guarantee you they thought of this for I
mean there's a couple of reasons Mike
the first and the biggest reason is that
Jerry Jones does not like to be held
hostage by anybody and you see the
reason this has lasted so long is that
he he does not like losing in these
situations that's number one and I think
number two he really really likes dak
Prescott he really likes him as a person
he likes him as a player he doesn't want
this to end he just simply doesn't and
so with that being the case that's why
you see why this thing gets so elongated
you know and and and it looks like it's
never ever going to end
so - my way of thinking is I look at
this right now I think the best
likelihood is that they get to July 15th
and he does play on the franchise tag
this year and then he sings for her
supper might if he's great and has a
really really good year then the Cowboys
are gonna be in the same position again
next year
of having to pay a ransom to keep dak
Prescott and it's like I say all the
time pay two million more dollars a year
now than fifteen million dollars a year
more two years down the road it always
happens with quarterbacks and you think
that 15 million number is crazy I don't
I think the best quarterbacks in
football when this cap really starts you
know to go nuts two three years down the
road it you know a really good
quarterbacks gonna make forty five
million dollars a year so you know
handle your business when you get angry
and it seems outrageous but it's gonna
seem a lot better number today then it
will two or three years down the road
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports